ah that is my dragon my rain has only
begun ah dude you have no idea can I
tell you what you want no [ __ ] part of
what I dragon oh you have a gun they're
bulletproof do they have guns but they
see better at night you ask them guns
but I don't know man games are thrown
yeah we're talking about geo today but
this is G hooked ah what the [ __ ] is
that in the skies and a plane is it a
bird ah to find Ryan run was nice you
want anywhere shooter good luck you're
gonna shoot what when will they have
guns in games the three got [ __ ] all
kinds of stuff they've got no see arrows
and Spears full yeah so why did you see
the shoot as well I'm just saying do I
happen know that they're bulletproof
just a me my girl into uh that Clint was
at the glendale galleria or whatever the
giant mall there yeah i went there cuz
we went to raffi's your spot okay went
to raffi's at the persian place yeah
cholos yes we took the baby down there
in glendale right and glenda and we
walking down there and she want to go
this juice place and um put in the mons
you know people and and well and we're
in the mall and there's like this big
line for juice i'm looking at it and she
can tell by my face I don't like malls I
went for her I don't like mall I hate
malls I hate being around to the game
and some sick I'm already agitated and
she was with you I anything on it nope
she was Wyatt you know it's kool aid
right she's like yeah it's that place
where they have like it's all like rag
call it fresh Julia I'm staring at it I
bet I'm stare at and she owes its know
whose are really good for you to know it
all right I can't hold it anymore no
it's not it's not there's no there's no
[ __ ] fresh juice that there's no
fresh juice I was like there's no first
you its first huh it's good iran iran
understand why mosquito diet I'm sorry
[ __ ] I on the same she's like oh they
up strawberry story oh god leader sir oh
thats a dude it's cyrah it's next to
[ __ ] [ __ ] a bun oh yeah that's I
would have been Oh ass waving but but
I'm sorry but in a way you know I'm you
like a Hillary people think they're
getting a healthy smoothie I know you're
getting 40 jobs just all that is 40
grandma sugar [ __ ] it's like this is my
honest for tiger you can't give him that
stuff give them brother Jim screech into
the LOL choir over here home you are
preaching to the worst that's where just
she was like I'm just gonna get a large
kiwi strawberry hey you either like
thinking about Tiger than my mind was
racing as I guess that dude that is and
then you it's almost like Ian oh look
Ian's there he does his work he's gonna
hang out maybe have a beer and then go
home yeah I mean it's not like hey Ian's
doing [ __ ] blow get in the back oh
well how old are you tell I never topi
with that it's [ __ ] hard to guess
like if you gave me guess I can't tell
you yeah could not [ __ ] it I like
people to guess and then just not tellin
answer exactly he's 67 years old man
that's 72 ordered a chocolate 89 but
yeah [ __ ] i bought John woman's purse
headshot that's oh yeah yeah Traci Traci
Traci Traci Traci zout there is he crazy
like a fox though does he know was doing
I think he's a genius yeah I like as far
as like manipulating just show business
like he knows like he got anyway let me
know he gets up he knows when to turn
his crazy on and off yeah is that right
so I'm wonder how crazy really is right
like genius like you said genius yeah
like a discipline probably he's got his
discipline around his comedy like he's
gonna make you laugh and he's gonna show
up and have and give you a great show he
might be crazy in the middle it might be
crazy to me like I've been the night
closer Tracy like in Hollywood Hills
stand on the table take his shirt off
right patty stomach somebody go get
pregnant tonight do like crazy [ __ ] but
but he's done crazy like easier oh ya
got trouble at the law a few times yeah
he needed a new kidney I guess his
girlfriend gave him his girlfriend gay
this is the this is what I heard well
yeah
well let me just start the story by
saying Tracy Morgan is the luckiest
[ __ ] comic I ever seen in my life
like within like a week of starting
comedy he started at the uptown comedy
club he got on maybe it's more than a
week but he got on their TV show as a
regular cast member then that show got
canceled and he was on Martin like weeks
after then after that he's a brand new
comic yeah ill hella hat then you get
hella hot then he gets on SNL then he
gets off SNL ends up did in his first
few years of SNL you didn't even really
see tre's now didn't see him Danny ends
up he heats up like four years in ya has
a hot three years then gets off that
show and somebody from SNL tina fey has
her own show puts him on that so that's
another eight-year run yeah then gets
hit in an accident not by just some
regular truck but by a company that has
been maligned in the media then nobody
likes so then they to save face has to
pay him after he lives through the
accident which is another part of luck
so much money that he saw they made more
money than all the shows that I just
mentioned from that one is quite an
array Kenny were real and he's good and
he's out back and his back acting and it
was a terrible accident he's already phu
quoc ter already got somebody got
killing somebody died yet another guy
Uncle Jimmy Mac died but the thing was
even before the accident I saw Tracy and
he couldn't see like he had kidney
problems so then he got this fiancé and
this [ __ ] happen to have the same blood
type luckiest [ __ ] of all time
so then she gives him a kidney and then
they break up hey guys thanks for the
kidney I gotta get ya and they marry
some other chick I like this is
brilliant it's just I just these are
just facts yeah you kidding you guys
like this this is right this has got to
be even when at his time a worse look
it's the best scenario yeah case Terry
that comes out of it
and it's not like he it's not like he's
a great actor he's studied acting
they're just something about that mother
something about it's like crazy to me he
has the it factor for sure yes yeah yeah
the it factor you know he kills it's not
an idea he's in anything he's in all I
will watch God knows that powers got
those eyes that always seemed outraged
she's like wow but apparently he broke
his legs I'm back like he's everything
he does is [ __ ] like fun people have
no vanity they don't give a [ __ ] the
lights out of that live man oh [ __ ]
their fans and be like I [ __ ] my bad
somehow the whole room feels guilty he's
great man he's got those comedy like
when hanging out with Tracy and having a
conversation with him it's it's that's
what I wish was on stage like those
conversations are [ __ ] funny man he's
just so animated yeah and just and just
and just paint pictures whenever years
hanging out with him and just hilarious
he's just so funny good he does every
detail is an air that there's a as he
needs a podcast yeah there's that he out
of podcast gitanos story time with tracy
morgan well there's one even do he's got
so much money not so much it why do it
there's that story about like how he got
out of like he creates this whole scene
in a bar he had this crazy bill he's
buying everybody drinks everybody think
that's silly right burn crash if that
Intel's right and me bought the whole
place two more drinks on me in Vegas or
what like crazy yeah like Vegas is
somewhere like he's literally the tab is
gonna be ten thousand dollars right and
next thing you know I guess what do you
know the story he knows up he gets up
and he gets in a fight but he's like
this guy's calling me a black man he's
like he starts pulling the race card on
something but the other guy was black it
was a weird thing there anyway literally
they just seem to get out a scene they
had to break up the fight to that's two
sides the bar the bouncer somebody falls
and hurts himself and he gets out they
kick him out cuz it's just like he's
made such a scene amigos and that's how
I brother gets out of bed his business
yeah he said I didn't do the story
Johnson's Bert Kreischer doesn't in the
stand-up apparently
you